Hello, and welcome to the
tutorial for the Dart Editor.
My name is Devon Carew.
I'm a software engineer at
Google and a member of the
Dart project.
Dart is a new structured web
programming language.
The Dart language is joined by
libraries, a virtual machine,
tools, and a Dart to JavaScript
compiler.
Today, I'll be taking you on
a tour of the development
environment for Dart.
You can download a copy of the
Editor at dartlang.org/editor.
This download also includes a
copy of the Chromium browser
with Dart support built in, the
Dart virtual machine, as
well as the class libraries
and the Dart
to JavaScript compiler.
Dart, the language, and its
libraries, the virtual
machine, and the tools
are all open source.
Visit dartlang.org for more info
on Dart, including code
samples, documentation, and
the latest Dart news.
So now let's dig into
the Editor.
First, when you open the Editor,
it comes up with a
page of some sample
applications.
We'll click on the clock
sample app in
order to open it.
You can see that it's opened a
clock project over here as
well some Dart files and the
main clock Dart file in the
editing window.
In order to run this
application,
click on the Run button.
And this will launch
the application
and a copy of Dartium.
Dartium is a special build of
the Chromium browser that
ships with the Editor
and includes the
Dart virtual machine.
It supports Dart natively.
But we also have a good store
for running your Dart
application on browsers that
don't support Dart.
We have a Dart compiler, Dart
to JavaScript, that compiles
your Dart application
to JavaScript.
Let's see how that works.
If you choose the Tools,
Generate JavaScript menu item,
it runs Dart to JS
and produces a
JavaScript file as output.
You can see the output here.
And there's a new Dart to JS
file in the files view.
We can open that file to look
at the compiled JavaScript.
So now let's run this Dart
application in a browser
without Dart support.
On the Run menu, choose the
Manage Launches menu item.
There we'll create a new launch
type, a JavaScript
launch, and select the HTML
file we want to run,
Clock.html.
We'll name this launch
and run it.
It'll invoke Dart to JavaScript,
and generate
JavaScript, and launch
a new browser.
So this is the Dart application
running in Chrome
and just running JavaScript
natively.
And an important point to note
is that the same HTML file is
running both the Dart
and JavaScript
version of the apps.
Let's see how that works.
Review the page source.
We can see that the HTML file
is referencing the Dart
application.
So this will run just natively
in a browser
with native Dart support.
And if you have a browser
without that, it invokes a
Dart to JS script, which first
checks to see if Dart is
available in the browser.
And if not, it rewrites your
application Dart references to
append .js to it.
So that'll invoke the output
of Dart to JS.
And your Dart application will
just run in that browser.
So now let's open a more
complicated example.
We'll be working with
this example for the
rest of this tutorial.
The File Open menu item.
We'll be opening existing
applications, and work with
them in the Editor.
I'm going to choose one
I wrote for the
purposes of this tutorial.
And it's open, and you can
see it in the files view.
And open the main file for it.
The app consists of a CSS file,
HTML, and a Dart file.
Let's run it very quickly,
and see what it does.
OK, so it's a visualization of
the solar system, with the sun
and the moon and a couple
of asteroids
distributed in there.
One of the things the Editor is
good at is navigating and
visualizing your application.
Because Dart is a structured
programming language, we have
a very good semantic knowledge
of your source base.
First off, let's open
the outline view.
This is going to show you the
types and methods in your file
you're editing.
So we see that we have a
planetary body class.
It has an add planet method, a
draw children and a draw self
method, and a solar system
class, which knows how to draw
itself and draws planets.
And we have two top level
functions, a main, which is
your entry point, and
a show FPS method.
Another useful thing we support
is hyperlinking within
your application.
So you can jump to the
definition of classes and
methods you use.
I'll jump to this constructor
definition and back and this
method definition.
And you're not just limited to
hyperlinking within your
application.
You can navigate into the
core libraries, as well.
Let's see an example of that.
So I want to see how this log
method is implemented.
I can hyperlink into it.
And I see the actual
definition of it.
And that brings me to another
point, that the full SDK
sources are available
in the Editor.
So you can see all the libraries
in the SDK, and you
can explore them and look at
their implementations.
Another feature we have
is the callers view.
This view let's you see all
references to a field or all
callers of a method.
This is something that is
possible because we have a
full semantic knowledge
of the source base.
Let's see this in action.
So if I select this window
field, right click on it, and
choose Open Callers, we'll
see that we have lots of
references to it.
And we can dive into those
specific references.
This is in our own
source base.
We can look and see in the
actual SDK sources.
It references the
window field.
And the caller view
supports finding
reference methods as well.
Another useful way to navigate
in the Editor is using our
search box.
So let's say that I know I
want to display a browser
alert box in my application.
I might not know exactly what
class it defined on or the
method is called, but I can
guess it would be something
like alert.
So let's type that in.
And I can select Occurrences
of Alert, and it searches
through the user code as
well as the SDK code.
I see I have several matches,
and I'm going to explore this
one in the HTML library.
And I find a likely candidate.
It's an alert method, and it
takes a string as a parameter.
Using the outline view, I can
see that it's defined in a
class called dom window impl.
And if I look at that
implementation, I can see that
it implements the window
interface.
So from that I can reasonably
infer that the window object
is going to have an alert
method on it.
Let's type that in and
see what happens.
I'm going to save and
run my application.
And we get an alert box.
So our search isn't just
a textual search.
It's a semantic search,
as well.
If I type in planetary body into
the search box, I could
see the type that I've defined
in my application and jump to
the definition.
We also have support
for discovering
documentation and user code.
Dart supports the notion of
literate programming in the
form of Dart doc comments.
Here's an example of one, and
here's an example of another.
A Dart doc syntax is a form of
markdown and is basically a
very simple, readable form
of inline documentation.
We parse it in the Editor, and
whenever you hover over an
element that's been documented,
you get a tool tip
with a Dart doc inline.
This is useful for SDK
code, as well.
Let's see that.
So maybe I've forgotten the
exact return type of random,
but I can hover over it and
see that it's specified a
return value between
zero and one.
Finally, all of our
documentation for our core
libraries is available online.
You can navigate to them
from the help API
Reference menu item.
The Editor has full semantic
knowledge of the user's code,
and it maintains this knowledge
by continually
analyzing the source code.
There's no explicit
compile step.
As soon as the user pauses
typing or saves a file, we
re-analyze the modified file.
Let's see an example of this.
In the start method, we'll
change the call to sun add
planet to sun add planetoid.
If I save, the Editor shows a
warning, saying it doesn't
know anything about the
sun planetoid method.
Now, this particular problem is
a warning and not an error.
The Editor thinks that it knows
what the type of object
is and what methods are
available on it.
But the final arbitrator
of this bit of code
will be the run time.
If this object at run time
does not support the add
planetoid method, the code
will run just fine.
If we run this code, we see
that Dartium threw an
exception and that it was a
no such method exception.
And it really doesn't think
that this method exists.
So let's remove that method.
And instead, we'll modify this
planetary body constructor.
If we change the name of it and
save, again, the Editor
doesn't think that constructor
exists.
But now it's an error,
not a warning.
And that's because sometimes in
our type system, we really
do need to know the type of an
object and especially when
we're creating it.
One of the strengths of Dart
is that it's a structured
programming language.
If you make use of the optional
types in your
application, the development
tools can form a good semantic
picture of your code base.
This allows for sophisticated
features like code
refactorings.
The ability to easily
and safely refactor
code is a huge benefit.
It allows you to work on large
code bases in bigger teams. It
allows you to change and modify
the code over time in
order to keep that
code healthy.
The Dart Editor supports
several refactorings.
I'm going to show off our
renamer refactor now.
Let's say I decide that this
add planet method really
should be called
add planetoid.
I can select it and choose
Edit, Rename.
Then type in planetoid
and hit Return.
The method name is changed at
that call site and all other
call sites.
And if I hyperlink to the
definition, you can see it's
changed there as well.
I can hyperlink back.
And our refactorings also have
full undo and redo support.
Another refactoring we have is
extracting expression into a
local variable.
So let's go to the calculate
speed method.
And if we look at it, we see we
have several constants that
we could reasonably extract
into a local variable.
We go to the Edit menu, choose
Extract Local Variable, add a
name for it, hit Return, and
we see it's done the
refactoring.
And it's actually also inferred
that the type of the
local variable search
should be a double.
So now let's play around with
one of the hallmarks of a
modern development environment,
code completion.
We'll go to the Start method,
and extract out a local
variable before we
create Mars.
And now I want to add a few
satellites to Mars, but I'm
not really familiar with the
planetary body class or which
methods it supports.
If I just type it in and invoke
code completion, it'll
come up with all the fields and
methods available on the
planetary body class, including
one called add
planet, which looks like
a likely candidate.
Now we want to create
a new planet.
I type in the constructor.
I'll let code completion finish
the rest of the typing
for me, including filling in
all the variable names.
Let's finish this up.
Save, and run the application.
So you can see that Mars now
has a new moon around it.
So code completion
is also great for
exploring APIs in the SDK.
If I navigate to the draw
background method, I can see
that we're drawing into
a context object.
If I want to see what other
drawing operations it
supports, I can invoke code
completion and browse the
available fields and methods.
So I see that I have some
shadowing operations
available, BZA curves, and
general drawing operations.
In order to allow you to use
untyped code and still get the
benefits of our Editor features,
we've included a
type inference engine.
It'll make a best effort to
infer what the type of your
var variable is and treat
it accordingly.
You'll get code completion as
well as verification of fields
and method calls, all without
having to explicitly identify
the type of your variable.
Let's see this in action.
I'm going to go to the
draw children method.
If you look in here, you can
see that we have an untyped
var planet variable.
Because it's in a for loop,
iterating over a list of
planetary body objects, we can
infer that planet itself is a
planetary body.
If we activate code completion
for that variable, we can see
that it does in fact have the
appropriate fields and methods
for a planetary body class.
And if we add a var foo
declaration, and try and code
complete it, we can see that
we get all the valid
completions for this
string class.
So the Editor has correctly
inferred that this untyped var
foo is, in fact, a string.
One of the hallmarks of a modern
development environment
is debugging, and the Editor
brings full support for
source-level debugging
to Dart.
We allow you to debug your
applications running in
Dartium, and support the usual
debugging suspects like break
points, variable inspection,
and stepping.
And one nice feature is that,
because of the way the virtual
machine is implemented, turning
on debugging by and
large does not affect your
application's execution speed.
So let's take a look at
debugging in action.
We'll set a break point in the
start method and run the
application.
This will launch Dartium and
connect the debugger.
And now you see we've
hit the break point.
We can see the call stack and
the frames on the stack.
You can navigate around and
inspect local variables.
Simple object types like ints
and strings, we show the
values of, and more complicated
objects, we call
the toString method of.
You can see that the Earth
object just says instance of
planetary body.
This is the default toString
result, but let's change that
to something that's a little
bit more descriptive.
We'll navigate to the planetary
body class and add a
toString method.
If we save and re-run the
application, we can see that
we've hit the same break point,
but the value for Earth
that's displayed is now the
new toString method.
And notice that we were able to
get the result of the code
change without having
to restart Dartium.
Another way to inspect
local variables is by
hovering over them.
So we're can hover over
the Earth variable.
And it calls the toString
method on it.
And we can hover over
the this variable.
And it'll call the default
toString of the
solar system class.
What's nice about this is that
you can see the values of the
variables without having to lose
context or try to locate
them in the variables view.
Now let's show some stepping.
Let's set a break point
in the draw
method and resume execution.
We hit the break point, and we
can see the values of the
local variables.
But more importantly, we can
also trace the execution of
the application.
So let's step into the draw
background call and step over
a few times and step out.
If we step into the draw planets
call, we can see
something interesting.
If we step in again, you'd
expect to step into the sun
draw method.
But we actually step into
the width getter.
This is because it looks
like a property access.
It's really an invocation
of a getter.
The debugger also supports
resuming execution and
terminating the process.
While Dart's primary focus is
on the web, we also support
command-line applications.
In order to show this off, we'll
open one of the examples
that ships with the Editor.
If you go to the Tools, Welcome
Page menu item, you
can see that we have a
time server example.
This is a simple HTTP server
that responds with the current
date and time.
We can click on it in order to
open the application, and then
click on the Run button
to run it.
For command-line applications,
just like in Dartium launches,
the process app shows up in the
console view at the bottom
of the Editor.
From this view, you can clear
the process output and can
choose to terminate
the application.
Let's run it again, and verify
that the web server is, in
fact, running.
So let's copy this URL,
paste it into Chrome.
And we see that we get
a response back
from the web server.
And if we go back to the console
output, we can see
that we've got several requests
for resources.
Diving into the source, we can
see that the application
imports the Dart IO library.
This is the main library for
command line applications.
It supports file and networking
operations, process
management functions, and other
operations useful in a
command line, non-browser
environment.
Again, in order to find out more
info about this library,
you can hyperlink into it and
explore the implementation, or
get more documentation online
using the API reference.
Thank you for watching this
tour of the Dart Editor.
To get more information about
Dart, please visit
dartlang.org.
And to download the Editor,
visit dartlang.org/editor.
Thanks again.